I discovered that he had put images up
on a porn site, of me.
So did the cops help you?
No, they didn’t.
Law enforcement doesn’t take crimes that occur online
as seriously as they should
My apartment door was kicked in.
They threatened to murder our children.
They threatened to murder our pets.
They stalked us…
I’m Ahmed Shihab-Eldin and this is a story about three women
with all-too-common stories of targeted,
online harassment.
I spoke with a domestic violence survivor,
attacked with revenge porn…
A former banker who was stalked online…
And a game developer,
relentlessly harassed
during what became known as Gamergate.
If you’ve ever heard the term Gamergate,
you’ve probably also heard the name Brianna Wu.
I went to see Brianna present her case
to a caucus meeting in Cohasset, Massachusetts.
Why is this such a serious issue?
Because the internet
in 2018 is our public sphere.
This is our coffee shop. This is our town hall
She spoke out about the male-dominated
gaming industry and got responses like this:
I hope you enjoy your last moments alive on this earth.
You did nothing worthwhile with your life…
even a video of a man with a skull mask
holding a knife up to the camera
and saying, "Brianna, this is going to be the last thing
you ever feel tonight, me stabbing this through you."
In 2017, 41 percent of Americans reported facing online
harassment during their lifetime,
an increase from 35 percent in 2014.
Of those, nearly one in five experienced
serious, targeted
harassment like stalking or physical threats.
Young women are especially likely to experience
sexualized abuse. One fifth of women between ages
18 and 29 report online sexual harassment.
It would have been so much easier for me to just sit
down, to be quiet, to keep my mouth shut, to do nothing
and just wait for them to go attack some other woman.
I was looking at lot of research, reading about your case
and here’s a lot of information that is purposely
intending to mislead people.
People love to click on dirt, whether it's true or not.
And right now Google's algorithm deliberately
rewards that behavior.
I wanted to understand why technology
platforms struggle to build safer spaces.
And why law enforcement sometimes
fail to take Internet harassment seriously.
I'm Liz Lee.
I'm the founder and executive director of Online SOS.
Online SOS is a non-profit I started it to help targets of online harassment.
And why did you start it?
Well, the issue is pretty personal to me.
I was just a girl out of college, I just graduated, moved
back to New York City, starting my first
job in finance, excited to be in the real world
and getting these strange emails.
I got an email that had kind of an implicit threat in it,
where like, "if you don't show up on this day,
I will do x, y, and z."
I didn't know what to do about it.
Do I tell my employer? Do I tell my parents?
It's one on one.
It doesn't matter if anybody knows about it.
It's just meant for the target to be afraid.
So, you said you were stalked.
My apartment door was kicked in, yes.
I was getting a ton of phone calls.
At this point, I knew who it was,
and it was an ex partner, and they were stalking me,
and I couldn't do anything to stop the phone calls.
Non-profits like Online SOS are often targeted,
simply for being outspoken.
An organization called Crash Override,
that started in the wake of Gamergate,
disconnected their hotline because of overwhelming
need for assistance with online abuse
outpacing their current resources.
I don't want people to suffer alone.
I think suffering alone and in silence
is the worst
outcome.
The benefits of an open Internet and the connectivity of
platforms have a downside
allowing people to harass others,
anonymously and easily.
My name is Adam Dodge, I'm the Legal Director
at Laura's House, which is a domestic violence agency
serving all of Orange County.
The Internet has also become the weapon of choice
for exerting power and control in
domestic relationships.
We don't typically see a case come in for a restraining
order that doesn't have some type of
virtual, or online, harassment component to it.
It’s a public health crisis hiding in plain sight.
Domestic violence hotlines in America
get 20,000 calls per day.
One in three women has been a victim of violence
by a partner during their lifetime.
We do over 1,000 restraining order cases every year.
A lot of those cases don't involve physical violence.
They involve harassment, online shaming, virtual abuse.
Next I wanted to hear from a woman
who was targeted by her ex-husband
with so-called revenge porn.
I discovered that he had put images up on a porn site,
of me.
These were images that he took of me, and… sorry.
One in 25 Americans have experienced
non-consensual, explicit image sharing
or been threatened with it.
That number rises to one in ten for women
who are under thirty.
What would you say to young people, to teenagers,
who share these kinds of photos?
I would just say, don't do it.
We had children. We went to church.
We did all the things that made us the perfect family.
We looked like the perfect family to everybody.
It was when I got out of the shower, and he took them.
How did you feel when you saw them on the site?
I felt completely violated and betrayed.
So did the cops help you?
No, they didn't. They
actually, one of the police officers
told me he wasn’t sure
if it was a crime, because I was his wife.
It just… doesn’t go anywhere…
a sheriff investigator filed it criminally,
with the DA, and then they rejected it.
Most states now have laws banning
nonconsenual pornography
but a national law has been stymied, in some cases,
even by free speech advocates
like the American Civil Liberties Union.
It's really important that we craft the law appropriately
to make sure that we aren't sweeping in protected speech.
Why is intent so critical?
Without a strong intent requirement, it could be a crime,
for example, to share an image of the famous Napalm girl,
the Vietnam protest photo.
The burden of proof often lands on survivors.
Both law enforcement and platforms
ask for documentation of images.
It’s a very humiliating thing.
It’s not something you wanted someone to know.
I asked her about trying to use the legal system
to get images taken down.
It wasn’t easy to do
but I got the courage to go to court.
I had to show the images.
Facebook also asks survivors
to submit images that can be flagged.
My name is Karuna Nain, I manage global safety
policy programs at Facebook.
We do rely very heavily on the community
to flag content
that violates our community standards.
We have some tools that run that catch
content like nudity,
like the photo DNA tool I talked about for catching child
sexual abuse images,
but we do rely on the community
to report content as well.
Just in the first quarter of this year,
Facebook reported deleting
more than 21 million pieces of adult nudity.
When you're building a social network
and you're excited about connecting people,
it's much harder to think about "Oh people are going to
find their ... stalkers are going to find them online
and they're going to harass them there."
Rahul focuses on algorithms
and the design of platforms.
It's important to note that the business models have
dictated how those algorithms behave.
Not any technology limitation.
Algorithms should be talked about like mirrors.
These mirrors reflect our society.
Three quarters of women who have been harassed
online changed the way they used platforms like Twitter
and Facebook.
And 32 percent of women stopped expressing their
opinion online on certain issues.
In order to do this work, I have to be more public.
If that leads to harassment, at this point,
I’m okay with it.
Numerous talented, outspoken women refused to do
interviews for this story for fear of being harassed.
I know a lot of women that,
when I'll say, "Hey, do you want to talk to this particular
media outlet about feminism?"
They'll say, "No. It's just too risky.
I don't want to be targeted."
We have a system right now
that really rewards women for being silent.
Hey guys, it's Ahmed. That was episode 2 in our five-part series,
about the dark side of technology.
Be sure to watch the rest of the episodes, right here!
And don't forget to subscribe to AJ+.